hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in islam net from norway are
establishing a masjid a tawa center
establishing a masjid to convey the
message of islam is one of the best
deeds a muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in norway you know this and
i know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
allah azzawajal will give you even more
i'm here joined with the main man
himself
the individual who's known
to be
a major influencer in the muslim world
as an individual where the young ones
and the children in the secondary
schools in the primary schools they all
know who he is
[Laughter]
we're talking about ali needs
it's a pleasure to be on this platform
after a long time on the same couch
absolutely and how what kind of an
honour must it be to be selling you've
been sitting with this
the man himself i mean it's some people
get lost for words some people like you
act ecstatically you know it changes
from person to person you know yeah but
i can see the joy in your eyes i can see
it when i look at your eyes absolutely
i'm here at your presence
[Laughter]
well i think that the enthralled
exuberance that you know that you're
manifesting and
the shiver the shivering excitement
that you that you just played when you
saw me i think that's a very typical
natural reaction timid
anyway so what do we have here what have
you got for us today so what we've got
today in charlotte i've um there's a
individual i don't know if it's calling
my brother now because i'm not sure if
he's become a muslim or if he's looking
into islam there's an individual called
andrew tate now this guy he's uh you
know who he is right he's notorious yes
i've been studying him very carefully
actually in fact i was going to be
speaking to him on a podcast and it fell
through
our schedules conflicted and stuff and i
think it was actually my fault to be
honest with you because i didn't um
you know okay
i'm sure you can rearrange that we can
rearrange but um i've actually been sent
some videos from brothers and muslim
people uh
that of his videos and this is what i
haven't watched so far so what i want to
do is actually watch it with you
and um
and then yes just to give it just just
just so people are aware we have been
studying this issue
very closely this issue of this whole
red pool movement you know would you
would you consider android take part of
the movement himself or
yeah definitely 100 he is uh and i think
it's we we are like i want people to be
aware that we are we are aware
we were just waiting for the right time
to come so this might be just like a
little taster yeah i'll be before you
continue with that i was going to say
that i did watch um his interaction with
eddie from the dean show yes and he came
across very humbly and respectfully but
then then i was also told that you know
this individual's um
you know he's he's on these kind of
platforms with uh women
who are low quality individual women you
know that you know dress in a certain
manner and they don't have much to offer
in life low-quality women
and um he lives is kind of like
what would seemingly from the outside of
a religious place it looked to be a
hedonistic lifestyle well exactly that's
nice so yes but on the other hand of
course he's uh you know established in
certain fields but then he's been
criticized from for for certain things
which i don't know much about yeah we we
need to touch up on this because there's
another extreme that's been you know
like the red pill movement yeah but the
thing is we will go into detail before
we get into detail the reason why i
bring this up is because as muslims it's
important for young men
to take inspiration
and to take as role models we believe
anywhere from the prophets yeah exactly
the prophet muhammad
is the final prophet we have prophet
moses and jesus and abraham all those
and how to be a man for example the
aspect of masculinity is to be derived
from the sacred texts to be derived from
the seerah naba from the from the
prophet muhammad's life
so i'm not saying this man doesn't
display a masculine so-called masculine
clearly he does to the point where some
muslim men are looking up to him
in some ways but if you want the full
package of masculinity of human
integrity then we believe that's from
the prophets and the companions and so
on so
this idea of trying to find role models
outside the community
and for andrew himself which i'm i'm
guessing is watching this video i'll say
to you that to be a complete man we
would say to be a complete man to be um
self-dignified in the fullest sense of
the word
spiritual future
you know uh perspective is to follow the
prophets uh and that will show you what
virtue is well let's let's watch this
let's let's push this
yeah let me tell you something
revolutions are nothing more than a
bunch of men in one place it's not women
it's men if you put enough men on a city
square pissed off a revolution happens
that's what the people in charge of the
world are afraid of so to make sure
there's no revolution what they do is
they construct as many
divisions amongst the peasants as
possible they make sure the blacks hate
the whites the men hate the women the
republicans hate the democrats and we're
all so busy fighting with each other
they can laugh from the top because
there's not very many of them and
there's a bunch of us i'm telling you
the reason in countries like america the
reason the law is so destructive against
men is very very purposeful they don't
want you to feel like a king they don't
want you to feel powerful you wake up
amongst three years if you have 10 sons
from 10 baby mamas you're gonna wake up
and feel like the man you ain't taking
[__] easy if you wake up on your third
year of a sexless marriage paying taxes
and your kids don't even listen to you
you don't really feel like rebellion you
don't have it inside of you this is why
there's so much male suicide this is why
men are so depressed this is why
everyone's so unhappy because the life
they try and create for men the things
they try and purport the ideas they try
and make us subscribe to are depressing
they want you as a tax slave they want
you as a tax slave they want you in a
sexist marriage with some old fat who
hates you that's what they want afraid
to leave because they'll take your house
and destroy your life's work and now you
want you to sit there and pay your taxes
until you [__] die this is all done
on purpose none of this is an accident
it's all very purposeful and in
countries and countries which are not
like this in countries where men still
have that masculine essence in countries
where they're still control of their own
household when the government tries to
become tyrannical it's far more
difficult to do because the men get
together and say you know what women
clean the house i'll be back in two
hours and tell these guys to get
and that's what that's that's the
reality of it this is a control
mechanism along with everything else
everything you see on tv this is my
final rant everything you see on tv is a
control mechanism all the [__] they put
on netflix is a control mechanism
telling you that you have mental
problems you don't have as a control
mechanism telling you oh you oh yeah you
can't focus on anything for two minutes
because you have adhd or you're
depressed and you can never fix it
they're trying to control you they're
trying to dampen your life force making
sure your woman doesn't listen to you as
a control mechanism making sure you can
never leave her without being
financially destroyed as a control
mechanism it's all control mechanisms
all of it from head to toe you have to
resist the slave mind you have to look
at it all and understand they are trying
to make a slave of you and when i say
slave i do not mean slave likely i i
mean the word slave they are printing
money from the sky and you're giving up
your life for it if they can create
something in unlimited amounts anytime
they want and you'll give up your life
and time for that said thing you are
their slave they don't need to use power
and control and whips anymore they just
have the the money print button it's
slavery and they need to make sure that
even if you know that you don't feel
powerful enough to do anything about it
all of this every single thing about the
modern world was deliberately
constructed to get us to a point where
they can come along and lock you in your
house for something with a 99.9 survival
rate and you're gonna sit there and take
it
anyway that's what all this [__] is
including being in a position where you
can't even tell your own woman she's not
allowed out with her friends to get
drunk with a bunch of dudes because
you're not allowed to do that if a wife
comes home and goes i want to go out
drinking tonight you're not going
nowhere oh i want to go out with my
friends from work you're not going out
with them men that's cohersive and
controlling behavior
bro you can't even tell you're not to go
get drunk with dudes
they'll call that abusive you're an
abusive misogynist you're andrew tate
cancel him it's insanity and it's all
done on purpose i don't want anyone to
sit here and think this is some accident
we've arrived at or that we're here now
and it's no big deal this is very very
purposeful because when you destroy the
warriors of a society that's how you
usher in slavery first thing the romans
did when they conquered the greeks is
kill all the warriors all the fighting
age males you leave the soyboys and
and then you can conquer it done
that's what they're doing to us they're
trying to destroy the warriors so my g's
the ones who are left
don't worry about
it we've got bigger fights coming up we
got bigger we got bigger wars coming
ahead of us so if you want to somebody
go [__] because i really believe the
next 10 years are going to be difficult
for men of stature i really believe that
so like to me personally bro there is
there is truths
uh into what they say what he's saying
um but obviously we don't agree with
like
a lot of the stuff they forget the
delivery environments put that to a side
um there is there is an attack like for
example why is it that if i was to tell
my wife
um that she cannot go out with
we don't live that lifestyle but like
let's suppose you know i was a
non-muslim and i and i had a wife and i
told my wife you know i don't want to go
out with your friends
why is that abusive
why is and he's right bro like if you
look at war in history and the prophet
peace be upon him also this implemented
throughout history that when you go to
war with a specific nation who has
transgressed over and over again usually
the men are executed
period why and the why it's you can see
because at the end of the day a man
plays a pivotal role um in the future
and also when it comes up to our nature
we are going to be rebellious you know
what i'm trying to say so that's within
our nature but why is it seen as
oppressive or like for example when i
like i took more of the end a bit
towards what he said is that a man
cannot even tell his wife
i don't want you to do a
so how do we expect anything like i i
thought i was listening to what you said
and it seemed like there was
there was more than one kind of
commentary here it's almost like a
political commentary in there there was
and it was a social commentary and then
you had like a domestic gender yeah but
it went from macro to micro yeah yeah
yeah and
um because it's authority politically
it's authoritarianism
okay so these elites that he's talking
about right so
how do they benefit from there are
questions i have on this on these
theories like how would they how these
elites benefit from
uh the lack of a warrior class for
example if if america take that as an
example as a superpower would were to
have a weaker military force what would
that do for its hegemonic power and then
this idea of the divide and conquer like
put these people here and put these
people here that's more terrible i think
you can you can make an argument for
that
how that links to
like what red pill pillars like uh
tomati and others they're called like
the gynocentric order
and these kind of things is
more difficult for me to try and
understand but
what he's saying in terms of the gender
discussion is interesting why because
when moral farron was talking about in
his book the myth of male power he's
talking about the definition of power
and he said the definition of power
is
the ability of someone to take control
of their own lives yeah okay and what
he's doing is in effect he's taking that
definition of power knowingly
unknowingly right
and he's saying look you're not really
in control of your own life because a
man is not in control of his domestic
affairs he's not in control of xyz all
these things that historically he has
been in control of and this is causing a
psychological backlash for that man yes
now if if that's the way it's being
phrased then there's great truth
obviously in that notion right
um and it's a counterbalance to the
feministic narrative which says that
well
what we have is an oppressive oppressor
oppressed relationship you've got the
patriarchy you've got men being
oppressed by
women being impressed by men and that's
how it works well if you redefine what
power constitutes here power is
uh the ability of a man to take control
persons take control of their lives he's
outlining examples suicide and
lack of domestic control or
payments or the fact that a woman can
take half of the man's income even
though she hasn't contributed to it you
know this kind of thing which frankly
islamically from our perspective
completely we are against these things
in addition i'll add to it for example
to the things like custody of the
children or the fact that a woman can
take complete custody and just through
the power of accusing a man
stop and prevent a man from seeing his
own children okay exactly these things
are really
these these things in society are
are deep-rooted injustices we will see
from perspective unfortunately what
we're seeing in the muslim community is
that some women are actually jumping
onto the bandwagon and taking these
i rephrase that a lot of women yeah yeah
not some woman a lot of women and so so
this is where this this discourse is
actually legitimate yes but where it
comes together into some kind of grand
conspiracy i think we would need to
unpack it a little bit and clean it up a
little bit yeah but there's certainly
some grievances yeah which which need to
be redressed
who else would you say well i mean like
like you said before like the whole
thing of you know world order look i'm
not really concerned about that right
now do you get it like there's an
outright attack in my very household i
need to fix what's in my household bro i
don't like right now i'm not care about
like the jaws come in and the antichrist
and you know
right now i have to deal with what's
happening in my house and the thing is
like i said before is that we speak to a
lot of brothers you know and this issue
what we need to understand is that
there's another extreme happening now
because
because the nature of men and women have
been so corrupted um and men are not men
anymore and women are women anymore
we're seeing it entering our households
and we are seeing the ripple effects of
that and people like andrew t which have
been told that the muslim youth are
looking up to him and speaking to
listening to him why
why is that happening wherever there is
an action there is going to be a
reaction and that's exactly what we're
seeing bro because when men are filled
and that's why jordan peterson is this
becomes so popular why because he
listens and they say well why is it a
lot of men listening to you why because
we maybe it's the fact that we are being
starved of our true nature why can't i
not be yeah i think it's really
important this is this is this is the
crux of the mata bro and we are seeing
it slowly slowly poisoning our ummah so
much so that now we have our muslim
youth who are looking up to andrew tate
now this is the reason why you know and
we have these private discussions yeah
um
me and you and a lot of brothers that
we've talked to we can see this coming
and we're actually preparing for it
because we can see the family unit is
being destroyed in front of our very
eyes so the thing is either
we come with a portion of the quran and
the sunnah are not extremes because
there's a lot of extremes out there yeah
brothers are going again i'll be honest
with you i believe there are people out
there who are going to the extreme level
of trying to be the muslim and rotate
and we're looking at it no no let's be
real here they are genuinely doing and
the thing is is the more they're trying
to show that andrew can become the the
muslim entertainer himself he does but
there's a lot of things that he needs to
do
and i think if you have a discussion
with him and arrange it please i mean he
needs to understand that as this is a
muslim
when it comes to islam sure polygamy is
there it's a perfect solution it's
actually a better solution to what he
has because he believes that he can
sleep around and do what he likes and
you know he has to come to home and
there's one obedient wife
i saw him with eddie he said that
something about four is all you need or
something like okay good good
islam is a solution for you
but i think you made a series of very
very good points you know and what i
would want to add to that is the
following
this idea that you said that you know a
man is being started his true nature yes
first of all we have to admit that there
is a nature of a man of course obviously
now we're living in an age of
post-structuralism and social
constructionism so the idea is
there is no nature of man this is the
what we've been told this is a
social construct but then for me do you
know this whole transgender kind of
movement right well when we say i have
gender dysphoria i want to transition
from man to female because i've always
felt like a man
that presupposes the true nature of a
man in the first place so there's a
contradiction here that lies within the
social constructionist ideology which is
that they on the one hand
you can't actually transition let's put
it in in racial terms okay you can't
transition from being white to black
unless there's such a thing as being
black and such thing as being white
exactly likewise you can't transition
from being white or male to female yeah
unless there's such a thing as being a
man exactly such a thing as being a
woman exactly so
born
what you what you were saying what you
were saying about the true nature of man
a lot of people i know
especially in the left-wing inclination
like proclivities from that side are
going to say well actually it's all
gender gender constructs but then if
it's a gender construct
then the transitions from one construct
to another would be almost almost
meaningless almost completely it's
self-defeating
it makes no sense to me so that's the
first thing there is a true nature of a
man yes and there is there is a
masculine archetype out there and it can
be manifest and this is what our
religion teaches yeah yes and it does
include things which are not in the
feminine archetype which for example may
include
increased aggressivity it may include
but it's not limited to
increased kind of sexuality and it's
almost like as if many men today and i
think we would agree even within muslim
anomaly feel like they've been starved
of being able to manifest that reality
without being shamed by society exactly
and that's why you have this extreme if
they engage in some kind of self-defense
situation or if they engage if they want
to be in a polygamous reality whatever
it may be know you yeah because you want
those things are to be shamed how dare
you you should in fact feel guilty yes
now you should feel guilty for that and
in fact this this whole politionist
nature that you have is a construct and
you're and you're harming uh people from
feeling like and it's in nature let's
get this right yeah polygamy being
polygamous
even they looked at for example gay men
and they realized that when it comes to
um they are still visually stimulated
yeah gay men yeah yeah it's the same
like you don't see that with men like
with visual creatures
of studies yeah so the thing is it shows
that if that's the case then a gay man
could also still be politicians with
this nature wanting to be with different
men
the point is this though that's within
their nature and that's why it's it's
seeked into brothers bro i speak to
brothers and they're like oh no but i'm
happy
hold on a second where'd you get that
from i'm like
hold on a second because i have to look
at the brother in the eye
like and i said look bro like and i will
break it down and he'll be like oh no no
if my wife was okay this time i'm like
whoa hold on a second that's your nature
so what's stopping you is that the wife
is being upset now the thing another
thing that you mentioned is that gender
cannot be social constructs because
jordan peterson talks about this because
if you look at scandinavian scandinavian
countries which are egalitarian yeah
that you will see that usually he says
it says men are interested in things and
women are interested in um people
and when you see egalitarian countries
like these scandinavian countries you
see the disparity growing yeah so he's
saying well how can that be the case
because if it's socially constructed
yeah when you put these things and when
you let them be okay then how is it that
these women like women tend to go to
child care and men tend to be engineers
yeah exactly and this is and this is
exactly the point that i think i think
probably is where pearson got it from
yeah because he he has yosem is uh war
of farron's uh
magnum opus or his main book which is
the myth of male power which he was
talking about when you look at the
trends of what women are interested in
yeah by nature
romance novels romancing this is not
something which they're being forced to
buy yes you're not no one's forcing a
woman to do and it's cross-cultural like
if you see this the fact that it's
cross-cultural and it's historical yes
it's an extremely difficult and
problematic case to make say well
actually women don't like love stories
and they don't like romance and they
don't like novels this is a social
construct because if it's a social
construct it seems like there was an
interestingly uh immense collaborative
effort yes uh in
conspiracy it's a mess no not just a
mass conspiracy the the biggest mass
conspiracy known to man or actually a
woman as well which is that all
societies have come together and says oh
women do this yeah even though the ones
in the most desolate and derelict places
and men do this you know there was a
study that i remember looking at some
time ago called bandura ross and ross
yeah when they were looking at the
effects of children what kind of toys
they like you know the boys like guns
and these kinds of things and the girls
like you know dolls and yeah if you want
to try and eliminate that from the
nature right say there's no nature then
we have a problem here so the first
thing is we have to admit there is a
nature there is a fixed masculine
archetype and by not being that thing by
not being able to manifest that thing by
not being then this is gonna cause
resentment yes it's gonna cause hate
it's gonna cause and as you correctly
said i think yeah every action has an
equal and opposite reaction if if if
if there's a segment of our population
whether it's women or otherwise yes who
think that men are this is going to put
them in an order in check or they're
going to get the best out of life by
doing this all they're doing is it's
actually exactly there was a
pediatrician pediatrician
yes so he done a study so what he did is
he got to this um
young um girl so he got a young girl so
uh there was there was two parents so he
wanted to carry a study i don't know so
he did is he got this young girl and he
gave this girl from a very young age
trucks to play with so she would start
playing with trucks etc and then once
when they come at the study um what he
did is like they asked the parents to go
in the room and when they went to the
room they actually saw the young girl
hugging the truck and there was a little
truck and and the girl actually labeled
the big truck for daddy and the mummy
and the little truck the baby so you can
see even when you've given them a truck
which is a boy's toy yeah yeah she
turned it into a
a mother and turned a little truck into
the baby so you can see that it's
innately within their nature and to deny
this is to be stupid
i think you've done a good job in uh
putting to put in the case and we've
obviously answered one thing i would say
to understand is that like this whole
thing about there's going to be a war
coming in this i think is part of his
nature that he he's he's conflict
orientated and that's for good reason
like i think he was a fighter before or
something like that yeah
i think every man wants to do this part
of our nature is that we are conflict
orientated you know
my
someone more effective than others
but what i was going to say was that
but uh but this this war against i don't
know the government whoever he thinks is
going to be organized yeah i think this
is a fiction that he's create a
dramatized fiction that's created for
himself in order to fulfill his own
nature i said i say to him look you
don't need to rely on these kinds of
fictions we have the religious narrative
exactly and for us as muslims there's
always a kind of jihad going on whether
it's an inner struggle exactly or
there's going to be an ounce of defense
or something like that yeah so i think
that one and this is what i would say to
tate and others that follow him from
muslim and normal science is that look
at the religion of islam because it's
not just about gender you shouldn't come
into rajata about the gender issue or
through the gender issue
the origin of islam is fundamentally
about believing and worshiping one god
whether your worship the all-knowing or
wise god that tells all human beings how
to live their life in a way which
wouldn't make them cognitively dissonant
would make them upset make them
depressed make them feel like they're
not manifesting their nature and in a
way which is commensurate and congruent
with the spiritual right path which is
what we call this
so i would say look into the quran
properly read it read the biographies of
the prophets read the bibles of the
companions of the prophet you'll see
masculinity exemplified in the in the
most manifest way you've ever seen it in
your life and of course for femininity
women can look at the mothers of the
believers mary the story of mary in the
quran and so on and one thing i would
end this video with is the following
the quran says something really powerful
on this whole issue of gender issues
which is
that do not wish what
the other one has basically
two men is a portion of what they have
earned
and two women is a portion in other
words it's a comp we believe in a
complementarity between men and women
this is the system
there are roles and responsibilities
that men and women have and islam puts
it both together such in such a
beautiful way
it's a perfect way it's a symbiotically
perfect way which allows both to
manifest their natures in the best way
possible and in a way which both will
feel spiritually connected to the most
high and most familiarly and
domestically connected to each other
exactly and let me tell you something
just to end on this here that's what we
see that's where it's going okay
when you look at a lot of women who's
coming to islam it's because they truly
understand and they come into connection
with their true nature yeah now what's
happening with the red pool movement is
that a lot of these men that's what
andrew state said if i was to bet on
anything in the next five ten years it'd
be islam yeah why oh yeah that's what he
said why did he say that because at the
end of the day his
i'm not gonna say it's true manly
masculine nature because i believe they
are transgressing they they transgress
in a bit when it comes to islam islam
will balance that to what being a real
man is because i believe his likes and
the rapport movement are transgressing
those limits of being masculine i think
they're going to be overboard i believe
there's going to be a phenomenon of a
lot of men like objects
of women
yeah let's get that very straight yeah
this is this yeah yeah you're going
abroad
exactly
lack of compassion yeah yeah he's
allowed for us to you know you know he's
giving us like marry twos freeze fours
etcetera and those after that who
transgress because allah has allowed you
to do justice
exactly exactly but allah put things in
place yeah for as a man for me to have
intimacy in the right place but those
who go and commit zina you've congress
now because i was giving you options so
the same with the red bull movement you
guys are transgressing when you come to
islam you'll have a balanced way of
being a true man and not trying to go
extra miles by posting ridiculous
pathetic stuff um that you
do to your wife over
which i'm not going to get into detail
but that's it i think there's more to
come this is a this is just a tip of the
iceberg this is a phenomenon that's
affecting our ummah and be rest assured
that me mohammed jabs ishan we are
closely working on something that will
have a fine balance that we don't have
our brothers looking up to people like
andrew tate yeah um and our sisters um
who are going to maybe uh put suffering
but when i mean suffering is because at
the end of the day
we need to blame ourselves as well
because as a muslim woman if you don't
have your true nature and be being
yourself and respecting your husband
don't be surprised when you have many
andrew tates or many adults coming to
your household because you can't just
blame that for every action there's a
reaction our sisters are also causing a
lot of muslim men to turn to that
direction so inshallah we will have
something that will be balanced from the
quran and the sunnah that helps us to
re-establish the family union and that's
where it is in the quran the sunnah
and this is what we call everyone to you
know quran
the prophet
muhammad whoever builds a mosque for
allah allah will build for him a similar
house in jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
masjid
yes
that will be something that you'll have
on your scale
you